[Musique]
au début de la pandémie Daniel Bélanger
était incapable d'écrire quoi que ce
soit à défaut de pouvoir voyager le
printemps venu il a composé certaines de
ses plus belles chansons voilà quand
nous c'est comment mais j'ai eu envie de
quelque chose de lumineux et on a beau
avoir le projet d'en faire un album
lumineux il faut commencer on sait pas
si la lumière va persister bonjour
s'éveille sur ma voiture et surtout de
mes courbatures et la lumière fut dans
les nouvelles saisons de Daniel Bélanger
encore une fois il a lui-même réalisé
son album dont le titre mercure en me
est tombé du ciel mercure en est un
titre complètement superficiel
j'ai même l'image et Mercure est un mot
que j'aime et comme je voulais faire un
album lumineux avec celui-ci mercure
étant la planète la plus proche du
Soleil je veux ça
[Musique]
de renouveau sauf le sur Daniel Bélanger
qui a changé de maison de disque et qui
est de plus en plus présent sur les
réseaux sociaux ces nouvelles chansons
parlent d'amour sans artifice de vivre
ensemble nécessaire et de cette violence
qui nous entoure
[Musique]
les composés de dernière chanson dans
les deux premières semaines de de
l'agression des Russes sur l'Ukraine
qui fait en sorte que j'ai mis des
bruits de bouche qui mettent des bombes
et des mitraillettes sur soleil levant
et
je ne serai plus jamais qu'avec des
fleurs c'est soit des fleurs tu marques
des fleurs je me suis dit bonne façon de
tuer les gens
avec des fleurs
[Musique]
entrer dans nos oreilles avec un premier
album son mercure en mi est un de ses
meilleurs il nous rappelle son
chef-d'œuvre de 2001 rêvait mieux mais
aussi l'échec du matériel le disque de
l'année en 2007 j'ai arrêté de réagir
aux albums précédents puis je me suis
dit qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je
ferais qui si j'avais aucun album en
avant ce qui est impossible
qu'est-ce que je fais sans complexe ok
joue de la guitare comme ça je vais
jouer de la guitare comme ça j'aime
c'est clavier là je vais faire la gueule
ok est-ce que ça ressemble à rêver mieux
les chaises matériels nous c'est pas
grave c'est moi
mercure en me l album de la soixantaine
pour Daniel Bélanger et pour ses
admirateurs il est celui de
l'authenticité ici où il fait depuis
mais Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]